hey guys welcome to another [ __ ]
episode of congratulations
crazy
[Music]
we got it on
okay so we've got let's look let me just
start out by saying chrisley got tom we
replenished everything we got all the
shits we've got make friends in the
comments we've got the the
crazy nice mint green hoodie we've got
that [ __ ] the new life rip sandstorm
[ __ ] we also re-upped on the og tie-dyed
[ __ ] life rips with the sweatpants uh
and and you could have that whole setup
that whole set up that whole getup and
uh it it's looking beautiful so go on
over to crystallia.com to get your merch
and also support the show and uh also uh
come on down to flex avenue and watch us
play some [ __ ] video games um
i've been starting grand theft auto five
and uh my initial thoughts are
it's way too hard it's way too hard to
[ __ ] shoot it's way too hard to drive
it's way too hard to do all of the stuff
and it's not it doesn't have as much
heart as red dead redemption 2. uh i
will stick with it and i will keep going
but red dead redemption 2 is going to be
hard to beat and everybody knows i
haven't heard one bad thing about red
red dead redemption 2 at all i have not
heard one bad thing about that game at
all i've no i have not read one thing of
bad about that and some i have seen and
heard and read some bad things about
grand theft auto some people just don't
like it and i get it it's the more
gangster game
it's the more you know run and gun less
storyline less heart kind of uh thing
but uh dude i mean i had to go to the
shooting range to work on my shooting
and i had to turn the sensitivity weight
down way low i mean the sensitivity on
this [ __ ] controller is going it's
it's unbelievable it's like the
controller's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean it's
just going
absolutely bonkers sensitivo and i'm not
i'm not it's like dude let it drag a
little bit you know let's do some
foreplay
right
let's start the controller off with some
kissing and then work our way to the
sensitive part but no this controller is
all [ __ ]
um
anyway
[Music]
i woke up today let me ask you a
question
dude
construction workers
when do you wake up
like when he when do you wake
up for starters
three
three a.m
is that when you just start
when you open your eyes
because
the construction
always starts
like
6 30 or 6. okay
or seven either way it's too early
okay
and i'll tell you why it's too early
like i get it even if it starts at eight
still too early and people like well
when the [ __ ] do you wake up oh yeah
they're not going to be on comedian
schedules or some [ __ ] nerdwell
schedules
they're not going to do that they're
going to start when the work day starts
okay fine
but still some people are still sleeping
at eight which means you're there
setting up at what seven which means
you're setting up there at seven if
you're starting at eight because i woke
up [ __ ] before eight and it was just
that great
get get gang rag
get gang
and i'm like they're just chopping down
every tree in the vicinity and then also
working on a house next door and then
also working on a house across the
street and also working on a house next
door to that house next door so there's
so many constructions going on and
there's guys in a tree also up above
just ring
ring
and i'm just in bed at [ __ ] 7 50 like
fall fall out
just fall out dude
i tried so many different things i tried
easing my thought i get up i get mad
then i get anxious and then i use my
breathing right i use my havening
technique that my therapist told me
about just just you know just hug
yourself she's like there's a lot of
science behind it just hug yourself and
i can do this when i'm in bed because i
can't do it when i'm angry at the dmv
right because then i just look like a
lunatic a 41 year old man hugging
himself right but i can do it in bed so
i'm trying the havening
ring
it didn't work i got mad so i got
anxious okay didn't want to pop a zany
because i didn't feel like stroking it
all the way out to zany island i felt
like just kind of
doing it on my own but the havening
wasn't work it wasn't working okay so i
decided you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna try and imagine
this is the thought i had a [ __ ] 7 50
in the morning i'm going to imagine
i'm the tree trimmer not the guy but the
tool
and i imagine myself cutting down the
tree
uh the the the the branches
as i'm falling asleep i'm like maybe if
i if i'm imagining myself doing that
i could fall asleep didn't work pop the
pill went to zany island all good dude
but that doesn't work so that doesn't
work but i only took a .25 zany island
trip and that's fine dude don't get on
me about how i'm a [ __ ] drug addict
cause i'm not it's prescription anyway
it's prescribed by my doctor but i will
tell you this dude
i'm actually fine construction worker
guys if you want to start
if you want to start
construction at eight
that's cool
it's cool if you do a full day of
construction because then it will end
sooner
day uh uh bulk wise like it'll end maybe
a week earlier if you're doing a whole
day of construction but man when i tell
you these construction guys
stop at noon or like one
and i'm waking up now at [ __ ] oh dark
30 ring
ring get get get get gang rig
ring get
because some guy got up at 4am and drove
all the way over and climbed up in a
tree and then started woke the [ __ ]
baby up calvin sleeps with the best of
them i mean he sleeps [ __ ] hard corey
sleeps like it's a competition
but not anymore with this ring again
right outside of his [ __ ] he pops up
like what the [ __ ] is that sound
and now
you're
you're just doing it
to now i'm awake
and you stop at one
what about the rest of the day dude just
start at 10
start at [ __ ] noon you'll still stop
at four when are you going to bed
construction workers oh are you mark
wahlberg is this like the [ __ ] well
you know you got to go to bed at 4 pm so
you could wake up at 2 at 2 30 and then
you could get that [ __ ] tree trimmer
you could climb all the way up in the
tree and they could just rank again get
get gang you could just rank
gang and just wake the [ __ ] up out of
crystalline calvin just wake him up
how are you [ __ ] doing it dude what
is this schedule that you're on everyone
else works when they [ __ ] work it's 9
00 a.m to 5 p.m cause trucker worker
guys 7 30 a.m to [ __ ] noon dude
also even if you are waking up that and
you're up at nine or ten or [ __ ] even
if you're up at 8 30 the last thing you
want to hear is ranking
it's the last thing you want to hear
when you're sipping your coffee and
you're turning on the [ __ ] cartoons
for your children or you're having a
[ __ ] piece of french toast you want
to hear ranking
king dude let me get through my cs stop
before ranking again geek
you understand what i'm saying this
constructor worker and dude they wear
the [ __ ] loud their outfits are all
yellow and [ __ ]
they don't want to get hit by a car hit
him hit him with the [ __ ] car dude
everyone's on their way to work to swipe
and sleep out of their eyes we gotta you
gotta move carefully around these these
[ __ ] trucks dude
they're bigger than the [ __ ] sand
worm in dune
so annoying
i wake up [ __ ] so anxious that my
havening [ __ ] doesn't even work these
construction workers are taking me to
zany island
with no rowboat i'm going to zany island
without a paddle dude
so anyway dude
that's how i woke up and i'm like [ __ ]
man i'm gonna be so tired all day and
it's all good though dude because i got
to pick up my car because the day before
dude i've had so many guess what i got a
lemon i got a lemon yay dude i got a
lemon yeah we thought that it was
because rats were living in it but it
wasn't that was just something else that
the rats wanted to do because the car's
a lemon and they knew it deep down
inside yeah
the reds had nothing to do with it dude
a [ __ ] rat flew out of my exhaust
pipe but
that wasn't it dude
oh man there's been so much wrong with
this [ __ ] car this [ __ ] high-end
car that i wanted to get that i've
always wanted in my life and it's just
[ __ ] awesome dude
and i just [ __ ] i finally got it back
they rebooted the whole computer they
thought i needed a new transmission i
didn't
dude and then and then and then they
rebooted the computer they recalibrated
everything i brought it back dude as
soon as i [ __ ] drove it out
i got it i i i got it back i drove it
out i went to go put the window down oh
awesome went to go put it up guess what
came with my [ __ ] fingers the [ __ ]
window flipper thing dude took it off
yeah dude i took it off i tried to pull
the window up and i took off the [ __ ]
thing with it man i took off the thing
with it so now i'm holding the thing
driving the thing
so [ __ ] pissed off shouldn't have got
a lemon is that this
shouldn't have got a lemon i wanna i
wanna buy a what's that thing 1982 car
commercial here it is dude he pulled it
up because we knew it because we're both
from the same area here we go dude
look what toyota of orange is giving you
every time someone says you got a lemon
dude i always [ __ ] say i always think
of this dude i always think of this [ __ ]
it's weekend a self-service sale it's a
whole sounds like a jack-and-off sale
every car and truck and stock is
discounted and the new low sale price
clearly marked on the windshield just
find the one you want and buy it for
less 16 salesmen available but only when
you need them huge savings friday
saturday sunday from nine pm to midnight
the self-service
[Music]
it didn't do it you should have got a
lemon
from toyota of orange do jingles will
stay with you dude jingle stay with you
your whole life how about that how about
jingles are [ __ ] absolutely from the
devil because they stick with you your
whole life dude they're they're the
herpes of music you could forget a
justin bieber song and those are catchy
as [ __ ] you could forget umba before you
forget and you shouldn't have bought a
lemon you'd just be walking down the
street and i shouldn't have bought a
lemon people are like that guy [ __ ]
hates fruit
from toyota of orange
that one that says [ __ ] go see cal go
see cal go see cal dude there's one
there's a car place the car ones are the
worst dude
in la it's always like come on down to
tustin it's always tustin dude and
they'll just be like go see cal and then
it will say go see cal go see cal go see
cal go see cal go see cal go see and
when i was a kid i used i [ __ ] swear
to god it sounded like [ __ ] i thought it
was i thought it was [ __ ] cow [ __ ] cow
[ __ ] cow gross
the mind of a sex addict
from toyota of orange oh you shouldn't
have bought a lamb and shouldn't have
bought a lemon
but dude
god damn man
it's annoying that uh that my car's a
lemon but it's a lemon and even my
[ __ ] assistant was like you know what
dude buy any every every uh
every definition of the word lemon your
car's a lemon you should get your money
back and i was like uh well we'll see if
it's fixed this time that's the thing
dude it's like an abusive relationship
it's like a [ __ ] thing it's like well
we'll see if it works this time well
we'll see we'll see if it works this
time because it's hard to get cars now
during covet everything's [ __ ] jacked
the [ __ ] up anyway
um so whatever i may be turning my car
in i may not i don't know yet dude but i
told um i i was i mean it's just so
annoying so now i'm holding the [ __ ]
i i got it fixed though
i had to go i brought it back and i put
the thing on in it and they they got the
part and they put the window in the
window where it works and the truth is
shouldn't have bought a lemon shouldn't
have bought a lemon
um
[Music]
that's it no you found it
is this it
wow one fire's just sending me random
links about cars and none of them are
right yes dude one fire that's so
[ __ ] amazing man i love when he sends
me on some unnecessary links
unnecessary links bro
um
dude i [ __ ] uh
how about the fact that oh do you have
it right here
maybe he says maybe he says send it dude
you're gonna send it or not is this it
you won't get a lemon here it is toyota
of orange you won't get a lemon here it
is
hello i'm alan maznet toyota of orange
for over 48 years wow so [ __ ] the way
he's hanging out
toyota here we go that means you're
driving a reliable toyota also means
you're getting the best deal on every
new toyota in stock
you know camry tacoma corolla you name
it here we go make an offer and drive
your news here we go here we go how have
we stayed number one all these years by
turning lemons
number one all over though here we go
why aren't they doing the thing
oh wow it used to go
so you won't get a lemon i shouldn't
have bought a lemon wrong from toyota of
orange
kristen thinks it's orange and i say
orange and i [ __ ] tell calvin orange
and she says say orange and i say no
it's not orange phonetically it's orange
and she said well let's look it up on
google and google guy came up and he was
like orange and i was like that's not
phonetically correct i'm right no matter
how many times she [ __ ] proves me
wrong yes dude
anyway enough of this [ __ ] i told
him how it goes i don't need to know how
it goes but construction workers you
need some more [ __ ] sleep dude sleep
when the world sleeps it's poetic
um
but yeah uh
i don't understand what the [ __ ] deal
is my son i don't know what to do he
loves time out
like he does something bad and then i
say that's it that's it
and i [ __ ] get the thing that we put
him in it's like a little baby prison
you know it doesn't it's no bars it's
not inhumane it's it's like a play area
but i take all the toys out and i put
him in there and he's just like this
just looking at me just like this
holding his
hands over the [ __ ] thing just like
and i'm like be mad dude
be upset that you're in there and he's
just
tata
and i'm like you [ __ ] up and this is
your punishment be upset learn and he's
just like tata and he just runs around
rolling around all in the [ __ ]
playpen and he's just killing it he's
out there he's killing it dude he's got
to [ __ ] kill her imagination he's in
his head who knows what he's thinking of
he's taking the [ __ ] gumdrops and
blues clues and he's just having a ball
he doesn't even need toys i mean he
likes toys but in his head he's like i
mean i'll use them to accentuate my
imagination
but my imagination rocks
put me in the closet i don't even care
like that's what he's like it's so
[ __ ] annoying i say no and he does it
anyway no and he does it anyway and then
i [ __ ] put him in the in the [ __ ]
thing and he's like cool got my
imagination
he could be like the most [ __ ]
biggest serial killer of all time
they'll throw him in the in the hole in
shawshank redemption and he'll just be
like oh good i got gumdrops and blues
clues in my head
so he just loves it he loves [ __ ]
time out i don't know what to do
maybe i should just sing him the lemon
song he probably would hate no he'd love
that dude he's so happy man
he started saying calvin dalia and he
goes karen ruler
and it's not even [ __ ] close
say it better
or say it closer at least do the right
amount of syllables i'm a good dad but
don't push me i'm a good dad but don't
push me
wow
[ __ ]
[Music]
hey guys i want to talk to you about hr
supplements
finding the right supplements to fit
your lifestyle can be hard enough in a
sea of marketing and hype brands often
skimp on what's most important and
that's quality ingredients
hrsupplements.com provides pure and lab
tested products at an affordable price
all right
hrsupplements.com
offers a wide variety of supplement
brands for all lifestyles muscle empire
for muscle conscious gym co goers
harvest naturals for the immunity
focused and for those needing to add
that extra bit of edge to their focus
and you know me your boy needs all that
and he gets it from hr supplements
hrsupplements.com makes it easy to
search by goals such as weight
management management muscle building
immune support and more
i personally am liking the pre-workout
powder um
it gets me in the mood for working out i
take it it tastes really good by the way
and then
i'm johnny works it out as as long as i
want to it's amazing with hr supplements
wide variety of products and brands i
can be the healthiest version of myself
and so can you their website makes it
easy to browse and
build my ideal supplement stack and they
even have pre-built stacks available if
you want to make it easier on yourself
that's why i love hr supplements and
it's why you'll love them too trust me
so treat your body right this holiday
season and head on over to
hrsupplements.com
to get 20 off your first order by using
my code congrats at checkout 20
off see you there
[Music]
man i don't even know about how [ __ ]
to talk about this goddamn uh
uh wyclef video
wyclef
dropped the ceo of jaguar in his goddamn
head
uh
let me just
let me just say it again
in case you think you didn't hear me why
clef john
dropped the ceo of jaguar
on his head
that sentence should never be a
nobody first of all
nobody over the age of four should ever
be dropped on their head okay
you can slip and fall and hit your head
but just don't get on people's shoulders
adult
also
ceo
into valuable to be doing that
hey
guy who's in charge of a huge company
ain't too valuable to be getting on one
of the [ __ ] fuji shoulders
why do you totem paul keep your head
level
wow worst totem pole ever wyclef jean
and the ceo of jack of jaguar
it's so [ __ ] dude it's always so [ __ ]
when somebody gets on somebody's
shoulders and they and then the guy
takes a step and you got to reach out
and grab the guy's hands and the other
guy's like this from under you and he's
like this holding you up and you don't
know how to do it so jerky and you're
secretly making these noises
but it's always loud because you would
only do that in a loud place you would
never do that alone in a silent place
look at this title wyclef jean drops ceo
of jaguar land rover on his head at a
party oh oh jaguar land rover i don't
what the [ __ ] is that just is it jaguar
or land rover is it bolted the same i
guess i don't know
dude it's so [ __ ] how he falls you know
he got super
hit hurt and rocked so hard because he
[ __ ] um
because he gets up when he gets up he's
so stunned dude
like that's when you're in the most pain
is when you're stunned like if you're
going ah [ __ ] oh
you're not as you're not in
more pain than when you're just like
this
you know
is somebody cooking
broccoli like that's what you're just
smelling all sorts of [ __ ]
because you got rocked in the [ __ ]
head here it is
wow this song
so [ __ ]
also let me tell you another reason why
you shouldn't be on somebody's [ __ ]
shoulders because if you are
dude a man's [ __ ] head is touching
your dick
and balls you're smooshing your your
nuts in the in the nape of a grown man's
neck
you're smooshing your [ __ ]
balls in the nape of the [ __ ] fuji's
neck
hey don't do that also hey
don't put the even worse part about it
is
if you're the guy on the bottom you got
someone's balls on your neck
dad from toyota of orange you shouldn't
have put someone's balls on your neck
shouldn't have put his balls on my neck
[Laughter]
from diana of
orange dude
whose idea was it you know
what's the deal was it dude i'll tell
you right now
why collapse
get on get on it is jamaican accent get
on get on the ceo is like well i don't
know get on come on get on hey also dude
if you're the guy in the suit
you'll be on the bottom
did the thing so [ __ ] [ __ ] i
can't believe how much the ceo of jaguar
range rover or land rover whatever it is
looks like the guy who [ __ ] would
give the transporter all the info for
his mission
i can't [ __ ] believe it dude and he's
just did and why club is so heroic in
the thing he's just like this and see
your [ __ ] is so clumped over and just
[ __ ] in the back of his neck
oh my god dude
here here we go
so [ __ ]
oh fell forward oh [ __ ] dude so stunned
so stunned smells broccoli
the song dude
this song dude
anyone use your love tonight
whatever the [ __ ] that's like is
and i wanted you your love
tonight oh just cracks his [ __ ] nose
wow that's hilarious also why think
about wyclef his [ __ ] journey that
whole time just like no no no no no no
no no and he hits his head too but at
least [ __ ] it doesn't hurt as much
because he has uh the g the ceo of
jaguar's pillow balls to [ __ ] break
his fall actually they're on the other
side of his neck
uh other side of his face wow somebody
just commented dupe
d-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-p
so here's what happened the range rover
the guy hired
wyclef john to play a corporate event
last night and he accidentally dropped
the ceo on his head
god what a bad [ __ ] idea dude all of
it man
dude the internet is so good and also so
bad
like god damn it they're both [ __ ]
living such a [ __ ] day now because it's
all over and everyone's making fun of it
and
you know back in the the 90s or the
early 2000s it was just the only thing
was just [ __ ]
it would be like the next day jay leno
would be like son the ceo of jaguar got
bonked on his head you know he was like
well fuji's you know so anyway so the
fuji's you know so it looks like the new
album coming out is my lantern
you know so anyway i don't know just uh
that's uh that's what it uh that's uh
what it's gonna be so anyway uh and then
go on to the next joke and then that
would be it dude but now the internet
the [ __ ] just lives forever
sounded like some of the fuji's you know
so some senior of you know
something that's uh some sometimes that
that's just all it would be dude
dude the casualness of [ __ ] talk show
hosts with their hands in their pockets
you know [ __ ] so you know you know
just another day at work you know so
just
sound the fuji so here's what happened
so the ceo of jaguar's balls were lonely
and he felt like meeting up with the
nape of the neck so anyway so you know
that's what it was
so anyway that's what it was
the nape of the neck so
um
yeah dude god damn what's the [ __ ]
fuji's one uh killing him softly and
then what's that what was the other big
one fuji song
um
what was that big one
no woman don't cry
no no i know that's not originally their
song but dude the [ __ ] they did that
one no woman no cry and dude i one time
walked by a guy when i was in high
school and he was passing me and his
name was [ __ ] brandon dude and the
guy [ __ ] was the guy who
would like eat 20 tacos and been like
and hey dude he would it would be he
would like order 20 tacos from del taco
and you'd be like hey chris ask me how
many tacos i just ate
and i'd be like how many tacos did you
just eat and he was like this is number
19. i got one more and i'm like oh cool
man you know that was that guy and like
everyone had that guy in his school but
this guy [ __ ] uh was that no woman
[ __ ] this guy walked by in the halls
of walking out of high school once and i
heard him saying and he was saying no
woman goodbye and i [ __ ]
never got it
what is it
or not here i come that's what it is
gonna find you and make you want me
already all night dude i'm good and
that's just me without even [ __ ]
warming up
wetty or not here i come
come come come come gonna find you
i'm and that's just [ __ ]
that's from jump you understand
that's without the [ __ ] meow mayo
oh this is so funny dude this video holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this guy got caught trying to steal a
package off of people's porch this is a
video one and it's hard to explain
without the [ __ ] video but holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's a tick tock
porch pirate caught yeah it's done
you're done
first of all the way the guy comes out
and just starts filming and he says yeah
it's done you're done like because he
got his license plate everything amazing
the cock-suredness of that guy is unreal
also at this point just tackle the guy
and grab his phone you know what i mean
like you're so [ __ ] so then this guy
in his toyota camry pulls back and
hits an embankment of snow it pops the
car up
and the wheel isn't on the ground
anymore
so
cops is coming the crook gets out of the
car
i guess
tries to push the car dude
it's two tons
this is so funny dude he tries to damn
your wheels are not spinning anywhere
and the crook by the way the whole time
crook has his mask on for covet not like
a [ __ ] crook mask on like he's like
yo i'm gonna steal your package and [ __ ]
your life up but i definitely don't want
to give you the disease that kills .01
percent of people
did you call
me look they're just having like they
get to the point where the guy's trying
to get the car
and they're casually having a
conversation did you call the police
yeah
[Music]
dudes mistakenly honking his horn
this is [ __ ] hilarious under the car
trying to dig the wheels keep going
gonna run out gonna run him over you
know wow it'd be amazing if they ran if
it ran him over
and gets back in his car casually like
so out of breath at this point you know
heart was pumping for so what it's been
this has been
a minute and 13 seconds already
of a mishap and the guys just now the
guy's walking up
my favorite part is at the end they try
to like help them they're like you're
you're not the car's not moving at all
because it's off at the watch
wow
it's front-wheel drive you need to you
need to get the other
tomatoes boulevard
it's front-wheel drive you you need to
get the the wheels on the ground
the [ __ ] guy dude he's trying to
coach him on how to get away he just
tried to steal a package of his and the
guy's like the guy's like you got it you
it's uh the wheels aren't on the ground
it's front-wheel drive and the guy says
please i know no please i'm sorry like
so out of breath and still has his
[ __ ] n95 mask on
then the cops show up amazing dude
and they arrest him
yeah it's done you're done
wow
wow dude
oh the [ __ ] you got to keep this is
what it is man you got to keep your cool
when the [ __ ] goes down you got to keep
your cool
right that's the life lesson from there
now i know what that guy was doing was
wrong
right but the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] him up was gotta get out of
here and he drove up over the curb and
that's when he went over the [ __ ]
snow embankment a little bit and his
wheel popped up if he had just kept it
cool breathed a little bit
backed out and then
three-point turned it he would have been
fine but his heart told him no no no no
let's beat extra fast because you're in
trouble and his brain went yeah the
heart's probably right
back up back up back up cut it cut it
cut it and then his [ __ ] it told his
whole body to cut the car way too soon
relax when some [ __ ] goes down relax my
baby just relax dude
be like james bond remember the pierce
brosnan james bond one of the worst
james bond when he [ __ ] when he just
tried to breathe through when he was on
the [ __ ] hospital bed and he knew the
cops were coming or whatever and or the
bad guys were coming and he had just to
breathe through he just had to breathe
through and lower his heart rate so that
he put him into a coma
it put him in he loaded his heart rate
so much that he put him into a coma and
he put him into a coma and then they
[ __ ] took him to the er and that's
when he got away
you can do that if you can do that
um
wow
crooks who [ __ ] up are amazing you know
i'm loving when crooks [ __ ] up
when they can't get the atm out you know
when they try to jerk the atm out and
their atm is [ __ ] they don't realize
an atms they try to put it on the back
bumper they hook it into a back bumper
of a truck and they just try to drive
out of a 7-eleven in the bumper of the
truck and the license plate come out so
they drive away and then the [ __ ] get
caught because the license plate is
there
amazing dude amazing
amazing dude dumbest crooks world's
dumbest crooks that's a [ __ ] that's a
show that honestly brian calling would
be a talking head talking ahead on in
[ __ ] for tbs world's dumbest crooks
those shows [ __ ] suck dude if you're
a comedian that does world's dumbest
[ __ ] you should be ashamed of yourself
like just start a goddamn youtube
channel you know
um what's the [ __ ] uh what's the
thing what's the thing i wanted to look
up oh the q anon guy
shaman the kunan shaman guy
this guy's a real [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know
first of all this guy
was in jail he's sent us to jail for 41
months
this is he thanked the judge at his
sentencing for
hearing for allowing him to have a fully
organic diet while in jail like dude man
you
no you don't get what you want and
here's why not because you're a crook
because you're obviously a [ __ ] crazy
person and if you're a crazy person you
don't even necessarily know what is best
for you or what you even want the fact
that a judge would be like sure that's
fine kale and butternut squash let's do
it that's so [ __ ] stupid
41 months in prison everyone's obsessed
with this [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i guess
he's the face of this whole storm the
capital thing but let me just tell you
something every time i see this guy this
is a guy who just is an utter crazy
person that looks so [ __ ] up but i'm
always struck with the fact that he has
the absolute
nicest set of [ __ ] teeth i've ever
seen i mean this [ __ ] is so lined up he
looks like a uh uh like one of those car
like rich cartoons that smile and go
ding
like that's how he looks with all this
guy dude
this shaman jacob chansley also known as
a q and on shaman
shaman uh inside the capital oh man i
watched that documentary it's so [ __ ]
amazing how these people are such idiots
that they think that [ __ ] they just
group think is the worst man they just
start thinking literally that this stuff
is happening
do your research anytime someone says do
your research i'm out i'm out
what how do you do your research on the
internet when the internet literally has
everything every opinion every fact and
non-fact that you can look up and it all
acts like it is a fact
there's no research that you're doing
you dumb [ __ ] wells fargo banker you
know what i mean you wells fargo or a
[ __ ] a guy who works at like a bodega
on the [ __ ] like what do you what do
you work at a surfboard shop oh you're
gonna do your own research and your
brain is gonna sift out the right
information your dumb is [ __ ] derelict
brain you know what's up nah but do your
research
it's too late
it's too [ __ ] late
and then i say well just trust the guys
at the top and they say how could you
trust the guys that's what they want
they want you silent and they want to
control you okay consider me
controlled
also my day is the same no matter what
you think [ __ ] dude biden sucks trump
suck they all sucked they're all at the
top
i was too young to even understand what
obama might mean i don't even know dude
every president sucks i've said this
before they got to make hard [ __ ]
decisions and they fail all the time
they're people
oh god i don't even want it i don't even
want to talk about it i don't care i
don't even care and you know what i
don't even know maybe biden maybe trump
maybe they're [ __ ] maybe they needed
to do what they did i have no [ __ ]
idea dude and i'm not going to pretend
like i did because i read a [ __ ]
article at the on the atlantic
it's so annoying dude do you re whenever
someone says do your research i write
them off i'm done nope nope i'm done oh
why because you did it
cause you did it guy in a [ __ ]
billabong shirt and cargo shorts oh
cause you did it
i don't know
i love doing this podcast
patreon.comcrystal no ads and also the
whole episode the rest of the episode
we do this cup for youtube but
um
appreciate you if you're a patreon
member if not we appreciate you all so
it doesn't matter we appreciate it
appreciate no matter what
but uh
yeah man
i wanna oh you know what i wanna talk
about is uh
i went to the haha cafe the other day i
wanna i wanna talk about the haha cafe
in north hollywood california
it's on lancashire
it's a such a great i started doing
stand-up there that was where my first
show was
um in um
[Music]
in uh in la and it was such a great
place
for young comedians to come up
and do stand-up and get stage time and
really cultivate like their jokes and i
did there a lot of people think i came
up through the comedy store and i did
but that was like i always felt like the
when i started doing stand-up that was
the open mic [ __ ] the haha was the place
and then i very quickly went to the
comedy store and that's when i really
like cut my teeth but
but the haha cafe was the place where i
would go and i would go every day and i
would start doing the open mics every
day and it's such a great place and i
haven't been back
uh
for probably 10 years and i just you
know my buddy was going over there why
don't you come and it's a new place it's
down the block now it's got a new uh
new uh
venue uh that's even that's nicer and i
didn't know
i hadn't been to it and i went there and
i saw terry who owns the um who owns the
club and it was so nice to see her man
she's such a sweet lady and i gave her a
big hug and i just wanted to shout out
the haha cafe because i went on stage
there and it was cool i went on stage i
was just it was a pop-in um i wasn't
even planning on really going up but
um
it was a show with a lot of young
comedians and it was nice to watch them
do stand-up because it reminded me of
when i first started you know and in a
lot of ways i still feel like i'm
[ __ ] figuring out as a stand-up
comedian like a lot of comedian that
people always ask me like when did you
make it or when did you realize you're
you could do stand up and i always
answer like i'll let you know because
um
it's a constant you know game or
profession of evolution you know if i
watch my old [ __ ] which i don't i don't
even watch it really period but
like i don't even know if i've ever seen
i think i saw a man on fire but i don't
i haven't seen my last one it's just
it's just i don't like to watch it
because i just
it's done after i shoot it but it's a
process and it's an evolution and um
so i was watching these young guys
and and i decided to go up and
and i went up and when i went up it was
kind of emotional for me man because
like i started there
and now here i am back there and these
other guys are now in this situation and
this position that i was in when i first
started and it was just a really nice
night for me man um
i felt like i got back to my roots and
it felt really good and i just wanted to
shut that club out because a lot of
people talk about the comedy store a lot
of people talk about the laugh factory a
lot of people talk about the improv in
la um but there's a fourth club and it's
the haha cafe and it's a great [ __ ]
club
especially for young up-and-coming
comedians man and they do weekends too
they got big guys there but like
i don't know man every now and then
there's a special night there at the
haha cafe and it's really [ __ ] cool
uh so support that club if you're in
north hollywood um
cause i love it and it was nice to go
back there and to see everybody again
i'm back i went to the bathroom you know
uh
bathrooms haven't been so good for me
lately i'll be honest with you guys i'm
going to be brutally honest with you
guys and it's probably because of all of
the
uh
man i had been good with my diet for a
while because also you know how hard i
work out and [ __ ] carry weights
around and and how stupid i go with the
kettlebells and i'm so sorry to break
your heart strong guys but i do i
[ __ ] get really elevated and super
angular with the kettlebells and it goes
and you know
you know i go [ __ ] nutso with those
but i um i've also been taking and
eating a lot of [ __ ] pizza i don't
know if it's because i've been thinking
about papa john a lot lately but god
damn i eat so much pizza it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
and one of my friends is like you know
pizza is not really that bad for you
it's got a good balance of protein and
this and that if you get the right
things on it and i'm like i let that i
let myself be tricked by that and i just
get pizza man and i got a pizza the
other day and i got dominoes and if
somebody's gonna slander dominoes i'm
gonna be all pissed off and you don't
want that you don't want me to be pissed
off if you're gonna be slandering
dominoes and then you come talk to me be
like you know pizza hut's better i'm
done with you dude i'm absolutely done
with you
i'm absolutely done with you it's like
you're saying do your own research
because to me that makes you a [ __ ]
because domino's is the [ __ ]
and yeah i get it there's other better
pizza out there but when it's midnight
there's kind of mostly not
so we got domino's and kristen was like
what do you want to get and i was like i
want a pizza with pepperoni and she's
like okay can we get half of it and i
say well let me stop you right there
whatever you want to get
you get that on top of the pepperoni
pizza that i want
and she was like but i want some and i
said whoa let me stop you right there
i want all of it
and i forced myself oh i forced myself
to get thin crust
okay because i'll tell you right now
i'll eat a whole goddamn pizza
and i'll try to do it slowly
but i won't
i'll eat a whole goddamn pizza very
very
fast
[Music]
and i did it
and i tried to do it slowly and i was
doing it while i was on flex avenue
playing video games on twitch i did it
but i [ __ ] did it slowly because i
was in between shooting civilians in the
game and taking chops of [ __ ]
pepperoni pizza
if you can't eat a whole pizza you ain't
[ __ ] dude kristen looked at me she's
like i can't believe i ate half a pizza
and that was crazy for her duchy's about
110 pounds that was not so not so for
her
but my god dude i built like a [ __ ]
sturdy house
i ate the whole thin crust pizza
and that was nothing dude i forced
myself to get it i could eat a whole
pizza how much weight as a matter of
fact how much pizza is there
okay that's that's the amount i'll have
you order for you we're never doing this
let's order for everyone type [ __ ]
dude cause then i gotta feel like an
[ __ ] where i'm eating most of the
stuff i'll get what i need and you get
what you need and we'll all be happy
dude and if you have some leftovers i'll
eat that too
the only reason why i didn't eat
kristen's leftovers was because she i
didn't i don't like [ __ ] cheese pizza
what a waste dude jeez you're not gonna
get some [ __ ] nice saltiness on it
with the [ __ ] pepperoni you're not
gonna put any mushrooms on it no supreme
shits no i'm not a meat lovers dude
because i don't like to get interracial
with my meats man
i do not like to get interracial with my
meats dude sausage is for sausage pizza
[ __ ] pepperoni is for pepperoni pizza
meat lovers where it's got sausage and
pepperoni and then because they call it
meat lovers they have to add other meats
in it that aren't even good on [ __ ]
pizza like meatball
dude
meatballs its own thing okay
don't put a meatball on a [ __ ] pizza
that's like putting spaghetti on a pizza
how funky italian can you be
at a certain point you get two italian
you're not italian anymore
so
like cheese is a waste that's a wash you
know what i mean you might as well just
get bread
but you put that pepperoni on there
you throw [ __ ] tree
some places they skimp out you know they
put [ __ ] one or two pepperoni slices
on the pizza
the [ __ ] out of here maron you put
[ __ ] nine piece you put [ __ ] you
split it up i tell you what you put four
and you put four another one or you put
nine on two right you split it up and
you cut it right down the center when
you're making the slices mod
right
that's the way i like my pizza dude
[Music]
um
so anyway that was really important
because so now anyway my
my poopies are horrible because i ate a
whole [ __ ] pizza last night
uh let's talk about let's do some
misconnections we brought it back babies
miss connections
um
and we picked some nice ones some nice
ones for for that ass right now
i know you like this connection here we
go here's the first one in uh la usc
norwalk area chub looking for his chaser
right to the point
latino man this is the body latino male
5 this is the body and the body if you
know what i mean latino male 510 bottom
chub
hiv std free ub2 wow use you know it's
like okay
into kissing getting [ __ ] getting
rimmed sucking looking for a regular
thing if you can host
it's a crass sit to the point so
disgusting
you know what's wrong with the world
into kissing that's my
favorite into kissing and getting [ __ ]
getting rimmed sucking pretty much all
of it
also like sex
also like [ __ ] talking just
everything here's another one jock
looking uh
okay this is the title jock looking this
safari
uh la based
tough alpha
tough alpha xxx tall man who promised to
let me play with his horse
please get back to me when you
get a chance thanks oh meat don't know
what it means so irish um
oh chance oh meet the period you period
i mean god this guy [ __ ] clean it up
a bit huh won't be disappointed i love
horses
this guy's like a batman villain
horse man
and ever since then i was when i was a
kid i was [ __ ] by a horse and ever
since then i've had an unhealthy
obsession with horses and now
i am
horse man let me know if you'd like oh
meet me
can we can we can we can we best him i
don't know he's so tough and he's such
an alpha he's a tall man who promised to
let you play with his horse
please hahaha please get back to me when
you
when you get a chance thanks oh meat
i love horses oh
wow
here's another one
fun-filled time handball that's the
that's the [ __ ] title
fun-filled time handball
this is the body gay white male looking
to have a fun-filled time engaging in a
little hand ball play with an
experienced top with small hands i must
travel dude what is that part of the
kink i can't get off if i don't travel
gay white male looking to have a
fun-filled time engaging in
a little
handball play
i get it
he's talking about getting jerked and
massaging his balls
not the sport
so
uh
[Music]
i must travel
just so
[ __ ] definitive
whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're coming over here i don't think so
and
think if you'd like to make a call
please hang up and try again
message c5
oh this one was removed wow one fire
sent me one that was removed all good
well maybe the guy got it got what he
wanted maybe he [ __ ] squirted it and
then deleted it
here oh here we go oh here we go here's
oh lesbian stud norwalk man norwalk is
some [ __ ] they got some
creeps down there that just love this
[ __ ] craigslist website
looking for a lesbian stud who secretly
craves to be pleasured by a man's tool
um
discreetly meet and polish my tool
polish
every time i hear polish do i think it's
someone taking a [ __ ] like a like a
rag to a [ __ ] and just like spraying
pledge on it
ride it or just let me smash those
cheeks uh sagrose
message back if this is you dude ride it
uh discreetly meet him polish my tool
ride it or just let me smash those
cheeks
wow
the great thing about this is you can
discreetly meet me and either polish my
it's it is good my body is good for
polishing my tool riding it or just
letting me smash those cheeks for a
limited time
i will be up and gone after you let me
smash those cheeks
or polish my tool
here's another one looking oh my god oh
and it was flagged for removal because
uh on the link here i could say he says
looking for a lady to eat out k
obviously got dismissed um
yo here's a good oh this is our [ __ ]
oh god damn it it's gone
man it got removed already dude he just
[ __ ] sent him to me this one's called
i miss the guys [ __ ] i wish i had that
one dude this one's looking for dave
looking for dave in laguna miguel and
then the body is looking for dave or
someone like dave he was a great flute
player
talking about sucking [ __ ]
wow imagine like being like wow i don't
know how i stumbled on this sex stuff
but
i love playing the flute and then you go
over with your flute
and the guy's just got his [ __ ] [ __ ]
out
and he and then the guy with the flute
opens his door and the guy's [ __ ] out
and the guy with the flute just goes
like this
uh
the gun with the fluid just goes good
[Laughter]
what a funny visual dude ah so excited
to go play the flute for this guy man
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome
oh
[ __ ] god damn it
i had a [ __ ] feeling
um
well that's it right
is that good
was that 53 and then we did the thing
okay cool
um well you guys thank you for listening
you guys are great and remember to go to
crystalia.com and uh pick up some merch
uh chrisley.com
and uh
had a good time oh let me shout this guy
out actually before we stop this guy on
uh on the discord on on my patreon
patreon.com
um
uh his name is will shotwell
and uh he's uh he may i get okay so well
he made this mess he wrote me this
message that he he always hoped that one
day would run into me at he says i
always hope one day i'll run into you at
a coffee shop somewhere i could buy you
a nice americano or four shots over ice
he lives in florida he can't do that
obviously uh so
he included a uh
a gift card to starbucks which is really
sweet and i know he's a fan so he knows
that i think that it tastes like the
back of a cow's mouth but also sometimes
i drink starbucks um but that's very
sweet um
uh anyway um
he he said i noticed you speak a lot
about doing what you are passionate
about on congratulations and i think
your words finally got to me almost 10
years ago i started a company where i
made small runs of leather accessories
and then quit because of a lack of
motivation
your words played an important role in
re-motivating me and it seems like all i
want to do is create
in a shop while i listen to your podcast
wow that's very sweet um this card
wallet is an example of one of my latest
designs and i think it's perfect for
coffee runs silly goose times at diners
and even covering tabs for brian callan
since his bank account is all dented up
um it all goes uh it goes on and you
know i don't know how much i should read
but it's uh it's very sweet and that's
very cool man so thank you and it's it's
nice you know i do this podcast because
um i i love doing it and i don't even
you know i do sometimes think about how
i you know people are listening and and
um
and how it may affect you and and you
know but i don't know i don't know and
it's nice to get these messages
uh every now and then so i really
appreciate your will and i appreciate
the gift that's really really really
nice and really sweet of you um
so yeah go check out his thing it's uh
resignation american handcrafted quality
leather goods
yeah
well that's it guys that's all for
youtube uh if you want to catch the rest
of the episode and have it be commercial
free and all of our backlogged
patreon only episodes there's plenty of
them go on over to
patreon.comcrystalia and it's just six
bucks a month
patreon.comcrystalia
go and just kind of snoop around have a
good time
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
let's do it
oh